il eut une époque où les hommes vivent
et sans argent mais certainement pas 100
richesse une richesse alimentaire grâce
à l'agriculture une richesse de matières
premières luxueuse grâce aux échanges de
sel et de pierres comme le jade
l'obsidienne l'avarice id
c'était en europe au néolithique entre
le cinquième le troisième millénaire
ces sociétés qui pratiquent l
agriculture est stocké dans les
alimentaire est très riche
une richesse qui pouvait même être
ostentatoire celle qui se montrent
qu'ils s'exposent par quels moyens
eh bien les menhirs ces pierres dressées
qui ornent les paysages de nombreuses
régions en sont un exemple
on connaît beaucoup de sites dans le
monde où sont implantées des mes livres
en asie du sud est dans le pacifique en
afrique mais plus proche de nous il y à
la façade atlantique de l'europe et plus
précisément le département du morbihan
en bretagne
et c'est là où je vous emmène
[Musique]
et
les minières sont des mégalithes
littéralement des gros blocs de pierre
un type de construction propre à
certaines sociétés que l'on appelle donc
des sociétés n'égale éthiques
il y a deux grandes catégories de
monuments la première est celle des
menhirs pierres dressées de plus ou
moins grande taille isolé groupés en
cercle ou en alignement la seconde
catégorie comprend les divers types de
dolmen
donc on sait aujourd'hui que ce sont des
tombeaux qui recevait plusieurs
sépultures
si on arrive à comprendre le rôle de ces
domaines sans trop de difficultés celui
des menhirs est plus compliqué et c'est
pourquoi j'ai voulu me concentrer
uniquement sur ce cas
[Musique]
au début du cinquième millénaire et en
l'espace de dix générations la bretagne
se couvre de ses monuments spectaculaire
de très grand menhir parfois graves et
de motifs signale des tumulus les
tumulus sont des masses de terre et de
pierres dans lesquels on aménage des
petites chambres funéraires dans ses
chambres on retrouve les objets de
valeur th poli souvent nombreuses qui
témoignent des changes entre les
populations alpines et automne mais
aussi des anneaux de pierres et des
perles de paris site
davari site est une turquoise d'un verre
talent provenant de galice en espagne
dans ce cas là les manières de plusieurs
mètres de haut sont un indice dans le
paysage et permettent d'indiquer
l'emplacement de la tombe
si l'art paléolithique ce mérité car il
fallait pour admirer les peintures
rupestres aller au fond des cavernes
l'art néolithique lui se montre à
locmariaquer c'est un menhir brisé de 20
mètres de haut et 280 tonnes que l'on a
transportés sur des dizaines de
kilomètres
autre phénomène troublant ce sont les
alignements de carnac
près de 3000 menhirs le morbihan est
d'après les cartes une région
littéralement couverte de mégalithes
[Musique]
on s'interroge souvent sur les moyens
techniques à ces époques pour dresser un
menhir en réalité c'est parce qu'ils
posent le plus de problèmes
une masse d'hommes des cordes une levée
de terre et un peu d'expérience
suffisent le plus intéressant est en
fait de saisir les raisons qui poussent
les ânes à se réunir pour construire de
tels monuments de leur plein gré ou pas
d'ailleurs
en tout cas une chose est sûre il faut
nous interroger sur le mode de
financement de ces constructions qui
commande qui payent le mégalithisme ne
serait-il pas le début d'une
démonstration économique où les
bâtisseurs agi sous la contrainte
obéissant un chef puissant qui donne des
ordres
c'est l'opinion de plusieurs chercheurs
qui ont vu dans ses constructions
l'émergence d'un pouvoir fort mais ce
n'est pas l'avis de tout le monde
j'ai donc envie de vous présenter ici
l'hypothèse de l'anthropologue alain
testart qui m'a particulièrement séduite
il faut dire d'abord que le mégalithisme
apparaît presque en même temps que
l'agriculture 5000 avant pour
l'agriculture en bretagne et 4700 pour
les premiers mégalithisme donc moins de
trois siècles les sait pas ce qui peut à
l'échelle archéologique de ces temps
anciens
testa rappelle que le début de
l'agriculture marque aussi le début de
la richesse les pratiques agricoles ont
bouleversé l'économie des chasseurs
cueilleurs
ils apprennent à partir de cette période
à stocker leurs aliments et qu'il y
stocke des richesses mais la richesse
pour faire quoi
à cette époque on ne paye pas sa
nourriture on ne touche pas de salaire
et les produits du quotidien sont
fabriqués pour la plupart par leurs
utilisateurs
la richesse ne peut donc être dépensé ni
dans l'achat de parcelles ni de
coupé-cabriolet
tout simplement parce que personne n'en
veut dans ce contexte les menhirs et ton
mégalithique servait sans doute aux
hommes illustres à montrer leurs
richesses ceux qui pouvaient s'offrir de
tels édifices étaient ceux qui avaient
pu réunir et entretenir une main
d'oeuvre
le temps des travaux mais j'en reviens à
la question déjà posée comment réunir
autant donne et comment les récompenses
et sans salaire
pour testard il est plus vraisemblable
que les menhirs et autres monuments de
ce type étaient érigés lors de fêtes
plutôt que sous la contrainte
pourquoi la fête et bien parce que dans
une société sans salaire une fête un
repas conséquences ont une manière de
rémunérer de remercier on y vient parce
qu'on sait qu'on y sera nourri et on
travaille pour celui qui nous nourrit
c'est la charge de réciprocité ça vous
paraît tiré par les cheveux cette
histoire pourtant quelques témoignages
noro de populations pratiquant le
mégalithisme nous laisse penser cela
dans la tribune et qu'il habite à bornéo
on a recueilli des témoignages d'un
homme qui prévoit d'élever une grande
tombe
et ça ça se passe un peu avant sa mort
pour cela il rassemble toutes ses
économies
c'est à dire de la nourriture en
particulier du riz pour offrir une
grande fête à tous ceux qui
participeront à l'ouvragé
une fois le monument érigé cet homme
espère que sa réputation de richesse se
perpétue et qu'elle traverse les âges je
viens de vous livrer quelques pistes de
réflexion pour les grands mais ni
redresser mais que dire des alignements
de pierre sur plusieurs kilomètres que
l'on peut voir à carnac
en réalité on n'en sait rien tout ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ce n'est pas
un cimetière sous les pierres aucun
corps pour tenter d'y voir plus clair il
faut aller voir ailleurs chez les
vivants
[Musique]
dans le sud de l'ethiopie de société
celle des comptes sophie celle des joies
d'un dress des médias pour les consoler
menhirs sont placés à la suite d'un
exploit
la victoire d'une bataille par exemple
ou pour honorer le mérite un homme
valeureux en plaçant la pierre
directement sur sa tombe et chez les
joies d'un fap le voisin des consos
lorsqu'un membre du clan meurt on creuse
sa tombe dans son champ sur laquelle on
dresse une pierre puis on vient
d'adresser une seconde dans le lieu
collectif
mais cette fois pour rappeler
symboliquement son appartenance au clan
ainsi des alignements de pierre se
forment sans sépulture
l'exemple le plus caractéristique et le
site de schalbach tout titi toujours en
ethiopie fouillé par l'équipe de roger
joussaume qui a révélé à proximité d'une
tombe recouverte d'un tumulus les
centaine de stèles d'aligner le tumulus
jouerai ici le rôle de point de départ
pour toutes ces stèles successives
car c'est la sépulture d'un ancêtre
héroïques auxquelles on voue un culte
on vient donc déposé symboliquement ses
descendants mort auprès de lui sous la
forme d'un mail ir bon alors je fabule
peut être complètement mais après tout
c'est le rôle de l'archéologie de
proposer des scénarios est ce que carnac
ne pourrait pas être un gigantesque lieu
de mémoire de 4 km ou des clans sont
venus pendant des générations rappeler
leur appartenance à une famille à une
société
[Musique]
les alignements de carnac c'était
peut-être ce qui faisait qu'on se
sentait morbihannais il ya 6000 ans je
vous la corde toutes ces notions sont
complexes culte des ancêtres
représentations symboliques monument aux
morts appartenance à un clan richesse
ostentatoire surtout pour le simple
pierre levée mais après tout
nous aussi nous avons bien notre
panthéon
[Musique]
ah c'est sûr que ce serait beaucoup plus
facile de dire que ce sont les
extraterrestres
[Musique]